hey what's up guys my name is the
channel i don't want to take up too much
of your sunday this is more of like a
little quick announcement as to what is
happening this coming week this coming
week
is game engine series week so for those
of you who have no idea what this is and
you would be rightfully so because i
literally made this up like
an hour ago what i'm going to be doing
this whole next coming week is live
streaming every single day much like i
did with falcon week
except this time working on the game
mansion series there are a few reasons
why i decided to just go all in and
spend the whole week working on this one
thing
namely the fact that i am uh feeling
like i'm a little bit of a mess right
now and i feel like live streaming for a
week straight is kind of like having a
real job and this will motivate me to
actually be productive
and do some work but then on the other
hand i feel like the game engine series
is at the spot where
you know we've got a lot of tedious work
to get done namely like the ui for all
the components and
you know rearranging just the basic
hazelnut editor stuff
so i want to kind of just sit down and
try and nail through that as
much as quickly as possible so that we
can actually just you know
shove past that and begin working on
some more interesting things for the
game engine series because i feel like
i feel like we should be getting to the
point where you can at least make a
little 2d game but there's still
a lot of work that needs to be done to
get there and i really want to get there
before the end of this year now because
this is the game engine series which is
like a video series on youtube this
isn't like vulcan week where it's just
purely live streams i will actually be
recording one episode of the game engine
series every single day monday to friday
now i'm going to be spending a lot of
the time outside of that in the live
stream preparing for the episode making
sure that i build up a good
kind of amount of code so that i know
what to actually do in the episode
and then the episode will just be more
or less like you know me actually
writing the code that i've probably
already
written before and played with before
but in the form of an episode so if you
if you can't catch the live streams
and you don't want to see me for hours
probably you know tinker with code and
get the ui
just right for certain things that's
totally fine you don't have to because
onto this youtube channel i will be
uploading every day
except it'll be like 24 hours after the
stream so starting from tuesday i guess
every day this next week there'll be a
new game engine series video up on
this channel now as always live streams
will be on twitch or tv slash the
channel i'll leave a link below to the
schedule as well just twitch.tv slash
the channel
schedule that will contain the schedule
for all these live streams and you'll
see it kind of in your time zone so if
you're not sure
what time this is going to be it's going
to be monday through friday 10 a.m
australian eastern daylight time is the
the target starting time for all these
live streams if you don't know when that
is in your time zone that's okay just
check out that schedule using the link
in description below and it should
basically translate
into your time zone now finally if
you're not able to catch these live
streams at all
but you really want to watch the actual
live streams and they will be saved on
twitch for
subscribers so you can subscribe on
twitch or even better you can support me
on patreon there'll be a link in the
description below
and you'll get access to all these live
streams as well as the entire backlog of
all my live streams that i've ever done
and of course that's the best way
to help support me in everything that
i'm doing here on this youtube channel
and finally if i was to leave you guys
with a bit of a meaningful message to
this video i would say that if you are
struggling
with any kind of development work or any
kind of creative work that you're doing
especially now during like lockdown
wherever you may be in the world
then really really consider live
streaming
what you're doing doesn't necessarily
matter if you have a large audience or
not
i think that live streaming is a really
good way to force yourself to kind of
be productive not get distracted and
actually power through
certain tasks and i think that in the
past has helped my productivity a lot
and that's why i'm excited for this next
coming week because i know we're going
to get a lot done
and i know it's going to be a blast hope
you guys have a good rest of your
weekend and i will see you hopefully
tomorrow goodbye